let's go next to our caller from the nine
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from nine one seven.
Hello, David?
Yes, that's you.
Okay.
Hi.
Uh, this is Justin from Brooklyn.
Hey Justin, what's up?
Hi.
I'm, I'll try to make this brief because I
don't know how many of these calls you get.
Okay.
I had last week watched a video from Kyle
Kalinsky about how people who are deprogrammed
from the right should call in Martha shows
and let people know that how you've helped,
right?
Yeah.
Didn't he?
Um, I think he played a clip of one of my
callers saying that we had deprogrammed him.
Right?
Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So I felt I should do my part and call in
and say thank you.
Oh, okay.
What, what were, what were your beliefs that
you were disabused of?
Well, if I, well, one thing I have written
down that I feel really kind of angry, not
so much anger in me when I started moving
out of my comfort zone, but I was a big listener
of, uh, Ben Shapiro's Steven Crowder.
Sargon of the cod.
Yeah.
Carl Benjamin.
Yep.
Uh, uh, Stefan Molyneux unfortunately.
Um, so I, I mean, I guess you could kind of
see the path I was going down.
Right.
And w the thing that I really, that really
kind of angered me when I started listening
to you, Kyle, Sam, is that they, the right
kind of creates this caricature of the left
of being these like people with, you know,
forgive my language, you know, sticks up there,
but, uh, you know, not fun.
They're racist towards that.
And I know this is gonna, I don't know if
this might sound weird to some, but you know,
the left is racist towards white people and
they kind of don't draw the line between say
you and the pink haired feminists that they
love to rank on so much.
And I think it's a, I think it's a great thing
because one person who did also help me out
a lot was destiny interest and when I yeah.
And Yeah, uh, one, one debate that I watched
that kind of brought me a little further down
the rabbit hole was one between Sargon and
Richard Spencer.
I didn't see that.
Let me down to, oh, it's a interesting, but
that kind of led me down a bit of a darker
path until destiny kind of jumped in and started
debating them.
Now let me ask you this.
Here's what I want to understand, and this
is something I didn't successfully ask previous
people who called in about when they had these
transitions.
What specific issue did you believe in one
way a what side of an issue were you on when
you were in that Dark Echo Chamber?
And then what is your position now?
Like pick any particular issue where your
mind has been changed?
Okay, so I guess let's, I could pick one as
being immigration.
Um, a lot of them like to throw statistics
of let's say, you know, one racial group,
uh, performs more crime than others.
Okay.
When in actuality like, you know, immigrant
groups, uh, don't commit as much crime as
native American, you know, American citizens.
So that was one thing that I kind of had to
reevaluate.
Um,
now that's an interesting one because with
a lot of these issues, what changes is people's
framework about the world rather than they
just are given new facts.
And it's that, I mean, you know, people like
Daniel Conaman will often say, you know, we
might think that if you just throw facts at
people, they'll change their minds.
But for most people, they're looking for facts
that support their preexisting notion.
So it's interesting that you mentioned that
one because it sounds like you're suggesting
on that issue of immigration, it's not necessarily
that your morality or outlook changed.
It's that when you believed immigrants disproportionally
commit more crime, you came to one conclusion
about what policy should be when you were
given the correct information that immigrants
do not commit more crime than native born
citizens.
Your position changed.
And that's a very interesting because for
a lot of people they come up with their opinion
first and then find facts that support it.
Yeah.
It, uh, it wasn't very easy to come to, you
know, the conclusion that, you know, I've
been wrong for awhile.
Sure.
No, I don't think that's really something
anybody wants to do, but uh, uh, it's, I'm
sorry I'm a bit of a cold, but uh, no.
Yeah, it's uh, I don't want to, you know,
prop myself up either, but the, Ya know, I,
I like to take the better, the better, sorry,
I'm a little nervous or no provided with better
facts and information.
I have to change my ideas because I would
feel disingenuous and dishonest if I didn't
because I know that
it's great that you're saying that.
I mean, that's just not the way a lot of people
work and, and it's not an ad Hominem when
I say that, it's just that we know that that's,
uh, that's how it works.
Justin, I appreciate the phone call.
I'm gonna run because I've got a lot of people
holding, but really great to hear from you.
Oh, of course.
Thank you for taking my call.
All right, Justin from Brooklyn successfully.
Deprogrammed great to hear from them.
A, okay, let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones momentarily.
Don't hang up.
If you're holding